los sudafricanos se apresuran a
vacunarse una semana después del
descubrimiento de la variante omicron
y hemos visto un aumento de la gente que
viene lo que es muy alentador creo que
se debió a la ansiedad por la nueva
variante pero creo que el público ha
escuchado al presidente y espero que sea
una buena señal de lo que está por venir
en un intento por aumentar la tasa de
vacunación antes de las fiestas de
navidad y año nuevo los puntos de
vacunación se encuentran en centros
comerciales y de transporte en todo el
país sólo el 36 por ciento de la
población adulta sudafricana ha recibido
ambas vacunas se trata de una
estadística preocupante ya que el país
experimenta un dramático aumento de los
casos de coronavirus
el jueves se registraron más de 11.000
nuevas infecciones la semana pasada la
cifra diaria era de sólo 2 mil 465 los
científicos del país dicen que omicron
se está convirtiendo rápidamente en
dominante tres cuartas partes de las
pruebas de muestras son de la variante
el 72% de los casos del jueves se
registraron en gauteng la provincia más
poblada de sudáfrica donde se encuentran
johannesburgo y pretoria es ahora el
epicentro de las infecciones las
autoridades estatales dicen que se
preparan para una cuarta oleada
dp estamos reutilizando las camas y
preparando el sistema sanitario estamos
volviendo a las cosas que hemos hecho en
el período previo al pico de las
anteriores olas no estamos entrando en
pánico pero estamos profundamente
preocupados por aquellos que todavía no
están viniendo a vacunarse en the fame
wave o micrones está ahora presente en
siete de las nueve provincias de
sudáfrica la variante está alimentando
el aumento sin embargo hay buenas
noticias las muertes y las
hospitalizaciones avanzan a un ritmo
mucho menor pero los expertos dicen que
tardaron semanas en ver el efecto
completo de omikron